There is a difference in the breads used
in the
>> Oh, that's what you're asking me. Yeah.
Okay.
>> Uh unleaven and leaven bread.
>> So, what is the difference when it comes
to using the different breads in these
traditions? Because I know unleventh
bread is used in Jewish tradition.
>> So, this is one of those differences
that
are not, how do I say this? There's a
freedom
in choosing whether you take straight up
bread like the Orthodox do or unleaven
bread because technically if the Lord
was celebrating the Passover
then the bread he broke would have been
unleven bread right?
>> Mhm. Yes.
>> So if you want to go unleaven bread then
you're being biblical. Now, if you
choose to go with levan bread, there is
no harm or sin. Because when we read the
term for bread in the Mathean, Mark, and
Lucan account, it's simply the term for
bread referring to any type of bread,
whether bread that's leavened or
unleavened. Any type of bread. All
right, let me show you. So, the Orthodox
will use leaven bread. Now, in one
sense,
both positions have deeper spiritual
symbolic significance. So, if you guys
are listening, I'm going to go unpack it
for you. So, is the Catholic Church
being biblical when it goes with unleven
bread? Yeah, because it was the
Passover. What bread did they eat?
Unleaven bread. And it began the feast
of unleven bread. So, yes, you go with
unleven bread if you want to just stick
with how they would have observed the
Passover. But does that mean if you take
regular bread that's leaven then you're
going no because this is a freedom to
agree to disagree. In other words, if
you take unleaven bread or bread, they
both have spiritual significance. So I
want to show you the spiritual
significance. But before I do that, let
me show you the word for bread.
All right. I'm glad you asked me this
question because I have I've seen even
Catholics and Orthodox go at it. I've
been wanting to ask you this question
for a while, but I guess it was tonight
answered because you had a talk about
the Eucharist.
>> Yeah, but I also answered it in such but
because Q&A I don't have the time to
then go through. Oh, this Q&A here are
the questions I answered. I don't have
time to do that. There is a brother that
will often leave comments. He watches
the session and then he'll put time
stamps. God bless him. Okay, the word
artos
right here. Artos
bread, loaf, bread, loaves, loaf, bread,
bread, a loaf. See, it's just the the
word for ordinary bread, properly bread,
divine provision. All sins God supplies
to yielded believers seen by scene to
live in his preferred will.
All right. Bread, loaf. So this is just
the regular term
used for bread, ordinary bread, but it
can also be used for unleven bread. And
here, food composed of flour mixed with
water and baked. There's made it in the
form of an oblong or round cake as thick
as one's thumb
and as large as a plate or platter.
Okay, so it's just used for ordinary
bread, but you can also apply it to
unleven bread because it's a generic
term for any type of bread, right?
Right.
>> Me so far.
>> Yes sir.
>> And here loaves consecrated to Jehovah
Bread used as a love feast and the
sacred supper. Okay. So there you go. I
again you guys get the point. So then
what's the significance when you eat it
with unleaven bread and you eat it with
leaven bread. Now let's go into the
significance. You guys ready? Let me
know if you're bored or you're learning
because I want to bless him and bless
you by extension as I deal with demons
and I have to hold down the fort. Well,
levan can refer to false teaching and
sin.
Levan can refer to false teaching and
sin. Okay. So, now let's talk about why
both breads
are acceptable and how they point to a
greater spiritual truth.
>> Are you ready everyone?
>> Yes, sir. All right.
Levan can refer to sin and false
doctrine. You ready?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, levan bread can mean Christ's body
was broken because he took our sin. See
how that works, folks? Hell yeah. They
know.
>> You got it?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, hold on, guys. You want to see the
genius of these churches? Why both
traditions are wonderful and beautiful?
Levan is used to refer to false doctrine
and sin. So when you Orthodox eat leaven
bread, what you're saying is the body of
Christ was broken because he bore our
sins in his body.
>> Ah
so then that's the significance.
So then why unleven bread? Unleaven
bread would mean would refer to Christ
being absolutely sinless and pure. He
has no sin.
You see how they both work? Hell yeah.
It ain't no. Here you go. 1 Corinthians
5:68.
Your boasting is not good. Do you not
know that a little levan leavenvens the
whole lump?
Now what type of lev he's talking about?
Clean out the old leaven so that you may
be a new lump just as you are in fact
unleavened. See now he's talking about
believers the body of Christ being
unleavened because Christ our Passover
lamb will also ass
sacrifice. Therefore let us celebrate
the feast not with old leaven nor the
leavenven of malice and wickedness. See
what leaven represents. But with the
unleavened bread of sincerity truth. So
he took leaven and spiritualized it.
You are the unleavened batch, the
church. So you have to be pure and
sinless. Sin is like levies. It spreads
fast and corrupts if you don't cut it
out.
So why was Christ's body broken?
Why
Rammon?
>> Because Jesus bore our sins.
1 Peter 2:24, who himself bore our sins
in his body on the tree. So if the bread
is his body, what did he bear in his
body?
>> Sin.
>> And so you see why it's leaven bread?
Because it is the leavenan that his body
took in order to bury it and destroy it.
So why do they give you leaven bread? to
show you that Jesus bore of our sins
>> and destroyed and buried it. Right?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, do you see the beauty of why some
traditions have leaven bread?
>> Yes, sir.
>> So that having died to sin, so why did
he die? He died to sin. Meaning the sins
we committed which brings about death,
he died that death
that we deserve. And so he bore the
sins. meaning his body was broken,
killed because of sin, consequence of
sin. So leaven bread means the body of
our savior broken for our sins to then
bury our sins and remove our sins from
us.
But if the bread points to Christ's
body, is Christ also sinless?
>> Yes.
So that's why the Catholic Church is
going to give you unleaven bread because
number one, it's it was the Passover
feast where they ate unleven bread and
unleaven bread means that Christ is pure
and free of sin.
So both are valid.
Okay, watch here now. 1 Peter 1:18-19.
Everyone got it? I love you young man.
knowing that you were not redeemed with
corruptible things like silver or gold
from your futile conduct inherent from
your fathers, but with precious blood as
of a lamb unblenmished and spotless.
So levan refers to sin, wickedness,
false teaching. But Christ is without
sin, without blemish. He is absolutely
pure and sinless. Hence unleavened
bread.
But Christ bore our sins in his body.
Meaning he died for our sins. And it was
our sins that broke his body. Hence,
leaven bread.
You guys see how both make sense?
[Music]
Proud of you, young man. Shoot. Cuz at
least 18, you ain't playing Xbox. But
what does leopard represent again?
>> Le what 11 represents, right? I can hear
you.
>> Yeah. What does 11 represent again?
>> Leaven represents sin.
>> Sin, wickedness, and part of sin is
false teaching. Right.
>> Yes, sir.
>> So that's why Jesus says, "Beware of the
leavenven of the Pharisees." Here,
Matthew 16:5-12. Coming to the other
side of the sea, the disciples had
forgotten to bring bread. Jesus said to
them, "Watch out and beware of the
leaven of the Pharisees and Sadducees."
Now they began to discuss this among
themselves, saying, "He said that
because we did not bring bread." But
Jesus aware of this said, "You men of
little faith, why do you discuss among
yourselves that you have no bread? Do
you not yet understand or remember the
five loaves of the 5,000 how many
baskets full you picked up? Or the seven
loaves of the 4,000, how many large
baskets full you picked up? How is it
that you do not understand that I did
not speak to you concerning bread? But
beware of the leavenven of the Pharisees
Sadducees." Then they understood that he
did not say to beware of the leavenven
of bread, but of the teaching of the
Pharisees and Sadducees. So leaven
represents evil and sin in its manifold
form. False teaching, immorality, you
name it. So when you are given leaven
bread, that's to signify Christ body was
broken and killed because of our sins
which he bore in his body. Bore meaning
he took the consequences, the effects of
sin, being killed, dying. But unleavened
bread means he is pure and sinless by
nature, a lamb unblenmished and
spotless.
>> That's incredible.
>> Cuz you're incredible, man.